so for people on
on this show who aren't familiar with
your background
give them give them a little bit of the
story you're basically
you're one of like the country's most
notorious diamond thiefs
well you know that we put thief because
it was a word that that's
actually better searched i was the
biggest jewel robber
in the country i still am known as the
biggest jewel robber in the country
i robbed 15 to 18 million i was hooked
up with organized crime
i wouldn't tell on anybody i ended up
going to prison
for four 12-year sentences
and that people ask oh why do you go for
four sentences because if i win one on
an appeal
i still got to do the time that's why
people go why does a guy get three life
cents he can't die
three times no but if he wins one of
those life sentences on appeal
he's still got life so that's how they
do that but i ended up going away
in 1996 and i didn't get out until 2007.
you guys were all young yeah and you're
you're a sound guy and you're
a guy he was still in diapers yeah
actually when i went to prison he was
even born
i know he wasn't because my daughter was
only 18 months and she was born in 95.
and i ended up i have a great
relationship with my kids
but my son was six i got out and he was
18.
and my daughter was 15 months old and i
got out she was
13 years old so i mean that's why i do
what i do to try to help people and
stuff like that you know
but i was a bad guy i i i don't [ __ ]
uh you know try to sugarcoat that i was
you didn't want to run across me back in
my day
i would lay people's arms on curbs and
snap them
jesus christ i was the kind of guy you
didn't want it but i didn't hurt
civilians we called it civilians
okay all the people in the business yeah
if you were a drug dealer you were a
bookie you wanted to be a criminal
you didn't want to [ __ ] run across me
it was that that's the way i was now of
course you know as you know me
and i help a lot of people i uh
i've a lot of people say oh you know you
only started youtube a year ago
and it's true you only started doing
youtube a year ago year ago and you have
over a million subscribers on your
channel
your channel is huge you do all kinds of
really cool videos
and we're actually trying new things
expanding new things
we have now obviously the podcast and
the tick tock and everything else
yeah you're killing it man but what we
we did you know and we're trying new
things you know
we got a great manager and peter and a
great team with my son
and darian and teresa everybody who's
there
we want to try new things so that's why
i try to tell me try it
it might work we tried gaming what the
[ __ ] does larry know about gaming
you know i didn't grow up with gaming
yeah but
what i did was um guys wanted it my
audience wanted it
the followers wanted it and we expanded
and i got into gaming i i mean i play it
i'm not good at it
by any stretch but you know we wanted to
try different
things so but i didn't start what i do
a year ago when i got out of prison i
started reality check and it's a great
story on how i started the whole program
i got out of prison after doing 12 years
okay 11 straight years
where did you do your time at maximum
security prison i was in
maximum security yeah i was i was in
atlanta usp atlanta
and when i was in edgefield i was
strapped down naked
beaten and tortured by guards and pissed
on
and spit on by guards because i was
fighting the abuses of the prison system
our prison system's broke
oh for sure and let me tell you it's the
worst [ __ ] prison system
in the free world and people what do you
mean i'm not talking about third world
[ __ ] i'm talking about france
italy germany spain canada the united
states is the worst prison system
in the free world and it's known and the
most people in
by by numbers that are do we have more
people incarcerated than
[ __ ] china per capita more not even
per capita
but straight numbers really they got one
point [ __ ] three billion people and
we have more prisoners than that jesus
it's just sick well they just straight
up they just sort of execute
everybody says that and that's not true
no it's not true really
what happens is they actually have a
higher suicide rate
because they dishonor their family
and they'll have suicides or they have
different ways they do
certain things so everybody's thinking
oh they just kill him and he's getting
that's not true
i don't know how iran works or you know
north korea works
but as far as the pre-world but i was in
prison from 96
to 2007 and i was
on conair 16 times that [ __ ] movie
did you ever see nick cage yeah nah he
wasn't on there with me
damn it i actually saw lou pearlman
remember oh really
backstreet boys and all that yeah and he
was the founder of
the backstreet boys and nsync and all
that okay okay
fat [ __ ] stole all that money from them
and and i when i when he was on a plane
he was he was i was getting off a plane
the plane
the plane and he was getting on it sort
of have you off to the sides and i saw
him and i said they're gonna [ __ ] you
lou [ __ ] you
and i was yelling at him and i'm getting
yelled at and all that [ __ ] and [ __ ]
uh oh my god he was like all [ __ ]
scared so what were you doing
you said you were fighting you were
fighting the system when you're inside
this way you got pissed on and
you got your ass beat by prison guards
what were you doing well you know
the prison system killed three of my
friends literally killed three of my
friends
one guy had a medical issue and he was
having chest pains there's his arms
hurting
goes to medical they say get out of here
he ends up going to work
they have what in prison you work you
work people think you don't work you
work
so he works what they call cms which is
like they maintain the prison you know
like the plumbers and this it's called
cms
yeah so he works with cms the guy who
works for a guard
tells me hey get to medical you look
terrible this guy james archer good
friend of mine lived three cells from me
mm-hmm
i used to play horseshoes believe me
they had horseshoes wow
they took them off [ __ ] yard quick
anyway he goes in there
and uh said they said get out of here
you got maylock uh you got uh here's
maylox you got gas
he walks into the unit he looks at
myself another guy named jimmy brown
we're looking at tv sets after he walks
in the unit and he goes man i'm dying
we look at him he's pale he sits down he
keels oh we put him in a chair
he keels over and dies right in front of
us
leaving the medical dies now i don't
know if you ever saw a man die i've seen
many people die
the first thing that happens is they
they
whatever's in them comes out but they
[ __ ] all over themselves that [ __ ]
you know it's just there's no nerves
holding it and whatever it is
so he died and uh wait they're yelling
lock down lock down you gotta run your
cell and all that [ __ ] and
when they picked him up they come with a
golf cart down to the unit they picked
it they were let i
now my cell was about three cells from
the main door on the on the bottom floor
and
i'm looking out we have windows this big
they're [ __ ] they're not real windows
you know
you couldn't fit through them you know
even you couldn't yeah good shape
not no fat [ __ ] like me
and they were laughing they would
thought it was a joke
and they came to every cell in the
prison and they said oh you saw him hit
his head
i said [ __ ] you you killed him i go off
on them
boom they throw me in the hole for 11
straight months
i was in the hole for three years out of
my 11
in the hole is that the same as the shoe
the shoe special housing
okay whole special housing segregation
just so basically you're in a little
concrete box by yourself yeah well
sometimes you're with somebody else okay
most of the time you're with somebody
else it depends on how bad you get
how violent you are or whatever it is
you don't get to see the light of day
ever
well you know they're supposed to they
call the give you wreck one hour a day
okay
and when you get wrecked it's in a dog
cage
a literally 10 by 20 cage
like a [ __ ] animal now that's when
they give you that
they don't always give you that and they
have the greatest line in the world
to not give you wreck for the safe and
orderly running of the institution
no wreck today bad inclement weather
no it's all [ __ ] they just don't
want to [ __ ] give you wreck
right so i've been in there i was there
when they didn't give you a [ __ ]
shower or anything for three weeks when
i tell you you don't know how bad you
smell
you smell yourself that's how [ __ ]
bad you
are no [ __ ] i mean nothing
i mean it's just disgusting what they do
to people i mean our system is [ __ ] up
but i was in the hole for three years
and
what am i a little [ __ ] up absolutely
i'm [ __ ] up
to a degree i think i came out of it
pretty good i mean
yeah somewhat normal and i think
but you know i i don't think people
obviously i believe in rehabilitation
i'm a different man when i was younger i
was
a wild guy i never ever say i didn't
belong in prison
because i was robbing i robbed 15 18
million
i was hooked up with organized crime i
was a violent guy
uh i didn't hurt like i was telling i
never hurt people who weren't in my
business
but that doesn't make it right either
you know i put fear into people you know
you're robbing a jewelry store never
hurt somebody during a robbery
never when i rob the jewelry store and i
rob one here in sarasota did you really
yeah i robbed all over the [ __ ] state
i have over 20 something stores
wow and the fbi got me but anyway
as i'm uh going to prison i go listen i
get caught it was a big deal when i got
caught and all that so it was mainly in
florida you're robbing me no no
up and down east coast okay i was known
as the biggest uh jewel robber in the
country still
am that's why i go on tv a lot on those
and i've been doing that
since i got out actually a prison but
anyway so
i never complained about prison again i
don't believe anybody should be
tortured i don't believe and i think
this should be rehabilitation
remember i went to prison at 34 years
old i got out of 46.
now i'm 59 i'll be 60 this year i was
born in 1961.
i know you're looking at me like you all
[ __ ]
i